foreign
thank you
can I have nominations for chairman of
the Malden District Council please
councilor stamp uh thank you chairman
I'd like to thank you for all your hard
workers I'm sure everybody else in the
council chamber appreciates everything
you've done you will be solely missed
even though we all have our
disagreements with your chairman
um but I would like to nominate
um he's gone no counselor Kevin Lagan as
chairman please is that seconded
thank you very much councilor stilts is
there any other nominations
I therefore declare councilor Lagan as
chairman of the modern District Council
[Applause]
there it goes there you go chairman yeah
thank you Mr chairman as well it's very
kind
oh of course
uh do we read this out
I think for a new message first of all
and foremost I Echo everything councilor
stamp has said um and I'd like to honor
um councilor Boyce and especially
councilor Nunn for all the uh the work
and commitment they've given to the
community over the recent decades it
certainly is a an honor to be here
um being born from this town my late
mother would have never believed it and
she probably would have smacked me for
being so Daft but it is an absolute
honor so thank you very much what I'm
doing here is I'm signing a declaration
of acceptance of office and I will read
it out for new members because it's um
it's obviously foreign
haven't been elected to the office of
chairman of the Council of the District
of Malden declare that I take the office
upon myself and will duly and Faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability I
undertake to observe the code of conduct
as to the conductor which is expected of
members of modern District Council
so it's the 18th the 5th
thank you son Mr Welch
okay so that was done
okay we move on to the agenda chairman
can you straighten your badge please I
didn't put it on no can you straightly
it's really thank you is that okay
yeah
thank you councilor stem
um we move on to the gender agenda
members and first the gender writers gym
is one as Chairman's notices
um there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through members we are
streaming this meeting live as well as
recording and by being present in the
meeting you're giving your consent to
being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
I ask when invited to speak you remember
to turn on your microphone and turn it
off when finished please reference a
page or paragraph number when referring
to the agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
and members for this evening's meeting
um the rules of procedure part four rule
8 subsection three the requirement to
stand when addressing the chair it will
be optional so if you care to sit you're
more than welcome but if you do wish to
stand you can do that as well so thank
you
um agenda item number four is
appointment of uh Vice chairman
um I propose to from the chair to defer
this meeting do I have this position do
I have a secondary accounts the stilts
thank you does everybody agree
thank you members
we don't need to move on to a gender
item five members
onto agenda item six which is apologies
for absence uh Bernard have any
apologies for absence please
thank you very much indeed burner
okay we move on to agenda item seven
which is disclosure of interest it's to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable peculiar interests other
registerable interests and non-regitable
interests relating to the items of
business on the agenda having regard to
paragraph 9 and appendix B of the code
of conduct for members members are
reminded that they ask also to declare
any such interest as soon as they become
aware as and throughout the meeting
thank you
members we move on to a gender item
eight which is the minutes of the
meeting held on the 30th of March 2023
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 30th of March
2023 which are found on pages 7 to 18 of
your agenda pack are approved as a true
and accurate record subject to the
following minor Amendment it's minute 12
and it's the update on the customer
service strategy and one modern District
Community hub
the SEC the second sentence of the first
bullet point under paragraph four of
this minute should be amended as follows
some members Express concern that is
being replaced with some members
expressed concern regarding this
if any message I I so move do I have a
seconder
thank you councilor stamp
okay oh can we agree those minutes by
Ascent members agreed thank you very
much indeed
onto a gender item number nine which is
public questions and there are none
received this evening
we moved to a gender item 10 which is
Chairman's announcements
members due to ongoing discussions I
propose that the following items of
business are deferred to an
extraordinary meeting of the council
which is now confirmed for Thursday the
8th of June 2023.
item 13 leaders and compositions of
political groups
councilor stem thank you
um but um I'd like to read something out
because I think it's very serious what
you've just done you've delayed you've
stopped what we would normally do at
statutory general meeting so I'd like to
read this in the best interest of our
residents and for this 15 709 people who
took the time and trouble to vote for 31
members of this Council would 15 members
join me right now to form an
Administration or do you want to leave
the council in limbo at such an
important time the residents should know
group leaders have had more than enough
time before tonight with no agreement no
agreed partnership working leave it for
another two weeks or not does it mean
that agreement will be made chairman
it's absolutely disgraceful egos Party
politics and spin cannot be put aside
and replaced with cooperation and
compromise after all that is what
residents voted for Council is to
represent them work hard and deliver the
best services for them and not ourselves
German I feel sorry for some of the new
members I bet they're wondering what the
heck they have signed up for I'm pretty
robust and I'm absolutely worn down worn
out and disgusted 31 members from this
Administration cannot form an actual
working cooperation Administration
the people we are letting down chairman
is all our residents so I urge you in
the name of democracy to support this
idea to form an Administration chairman
can I have a show of hands please it's a
sad sad day for democracy what's
happening at this Council thank you
thank you very much councilor stamp um
well in the light of councilor stamp
statement I'll put it to the chamber is
there a show of hands to former
Administration this evening
recorded please just bear with me one
moment please
sexy
okay well as members um I've just taken
some advice from Mr quelch and I think
that although we can actually um
register our agreement with counselor
stamp I think we will not take that
forward at this moment in time
um and stick to what the announcements
actually say councilor fluke
I think it's really important that you
use this meeting this evening to at
least give a clear timeline as to to
where we're going with this
um I hear I hear today that there is a
meeting on the 8th of June chairman but
you know I've said it before and I've
said it elsewhere this council's looking
at a deficit of 800 000 pounds this year
by the time we get to the 8th of June
um 68 000 pounds would have been taken
out of reserves to plop up this Council
and its work terminates taxpayers money
is unacceptable this situation has to
change and it has to change quick and
and I'm sorry but you know I've not been
privy to any notes or any information
uh that's come out of these meetings
between the leaders and nothing I've
seen so far has convinced me that the
situation will be any different chairman
on the 8th of June but Gem and I am
heartened by one thing and I found out
tonight that the the toy party
um who refused to try and uh uh form an
Administration their membership has now
gone from 10 to 7 and I hope that that
opens the door for some well-rounded
interaction between the other 24 members
if I've got it right thank you thank you
just make a comment on the uh something
you did say
um the meetings between the the leaders
were informal meetings and there were no
minutes taken to distribute around
whether the leaders of the the
um the groups decide that that's
something that they would like to do
that's down to them at the next time
that they meet
um but I thank you for that
so I'll carry on we got to item 14. this
is to do with deferrals
um item 14 appointment of the membership
of appointing Committees of the council
with the exception of Licensing District
planning and area planning committees
item 15 in the agenda a German of
meeting for special meetings of
committees item 18 appointment of
Representatives to local government and
outside bodies
item 19 appointment of members to serve
on working groups of the council ISO
move do I have a second
okay if councilor said I said all thank
you councilor members to be ready to
vote on this are we in agreement with
this
agreed thank you agree by send Cara
thank you very much now we come to a a
rather Pleasant part of the proceedings
this evening I'd like to invite up to
the the front table councilor Stephen
Nunn please
um Stephen's going to present some
member long Service Awards
um to councilman would you care to uh
come to the front
appointments
Freudian slipper Mr Nan
absolutely feel free so
great pleasure to present some
non-service certificates to outgoing
members you might wonder why I'm doing
this that's because the first
certificate is to encounter the
ex-counselor uh
uh
congratulations
[Applause]
in addition again
gives me great pleasure to present to
you both um the past Chairman's badge oh
um thank you very much
um the next long service certificate I'm
very pleased to present is to Mr Richard
Dillon
thank you
[Applause]
can I just say that 32 years ago
I was still recovering from the shock of
actually being elected I never expected
to be here this long
very much
we've got two other certificates here
but unfortunately the people in question
aren't present so there's one for Penny
Channer and there's another one for
Brian Beale that I'm sure that um boss
will make arrangements to nothing
thank you Mr nun we'll make arrangements
thank you very much
[Applause]
okay members and once again thank you
Stephen
um we move on to agenda item 11 which is
minutes of meetings of the council and
it's to note that since the last meeting
of the council and up until Wednesday
the 10th of May 2023 a council of gender
dispatch the Committees listed have met
to receive any questions in accordance
with Council and committee procedural
6.2
if any member wishes to raise a question
in relation to the minutes of this
meeting please make this known
members are you happy to note those
minutes thank you members
move on to agenda item 12 members which
is questions in accordance with
procedural six two of which notice has
been given of which there are none
we move to a gender item 13 leaders and
compositions of political groups this is
to be to be deferred
gender item 14 which is appointment of
memberships of Committees of the council
and we're deferred with the exception of
the licensing District planning and area
planning committees
okay
um I'm there to re uh the we moved to
the agenda 14 to point a membership of
the Committees of the council which was
circulated day and found in the
supplementary pack on pages three to ten
there are some recommendations which I
am to propose and they are three
recommendations recommendation one that
the member nominations set out an
appendix a be approved
appendix uh recommended little Roman 2
that the non-aligned member is appointed
to sit on the licensing committee as set
out on appendix a
and little Roman 3 that members know the
chairperson's job description in
appendix B ahead of appointments to
chairpersons of these committees ISO
move do I have a seconder counselor
stilts thank you
and many members wish to speak
in terms of the licensing
Council of neighbor
you put the microphone in sorry for
seven uh with regards to the licensing
committee councilor leyburn has stood
down from that about taking the place
yep thank you very much indeed councilor
Morgan
um there are three non-aligned
councilors
um we have uh councilor Bell councilor
lay and councilor siddle Norman and we
need to take a vote by a show of hands
four against her absain or agree
um by Ascent unless the non-alai members
have come to an arrangement themselves
about which to stand
councilor lay
thank you Mr chairman the three members
of the leading of the um non-aligned
party have agreed through and I've
agreed three not a line I agree that
this is this in relation to the
licensing yes
that my name will be put forward lovely
thank you Mr Chang thank you very much
indeed so take a vote of a show of hands
on this for against or abstain for
Council lay
or that seems to be overwhelming support
so thank you very much indeed members so
let's cancel the ladies appointed to
licensing
we move to a gender item 15 a German of
meeting that's been deferred our agenda
item 16 which would have been the
resumption of business that's been
deferred now members we move on to a
gender writers 17 which is a five-year
housing land Supply
we moved to a gender item 17 five-year
housing land Supply which is found on
pages 19 to 36. the chairman of the
council is to present the report and I
will move the recommendations in the
report as as below
we have two recommendations
and the recommendations are
recommendation one that the briefing
paper attended to the appended to this
report at appendix a and it's
accompanying spreadsheets provides
evidence that the council can
demonstrate a supply of specific
deliverable sites sufficient to provide
for
6.35 years worth of housing against the
council's identified housing
requirements
and recommendation little two that the
five-year housing land Supply position
be approved and published on the
council's website ISO move do I have a
secondary councilor stamp thank you
any members wish to speak
councilor Fluker please I mean look this
is this is exceptionally good news
German exceptionally good news and it's
going to stop speculative applications
coming uh to this plan this planning
Authority which I take a lot of comfort
in because my own Ward is particularly
attack particularly in an attack at the
moment but Gemini I I appreciate that
things change last July in the
methodology of how we actually approach
this
but I still find it really really
difficult to understand how we went how
we went from at the worst which was
about 2.88 to
6.12 or whatever it is at the moment and
chairman what concerns me as normalcy is
is that during that period there were
lots of speculative developments that
came forward which were approved on the
basis that this local Authority said it
didn't have a five-year housing land
Supply and even though I've read that
report I do think chairman that it
should be scrutinized elsewhere to make
sure that we did get it right thank you
thank you very much the councilor fluter
and I'm in full agreement with what you
said there
um any other members wish to speak
okay members so we need to take a shower
of hands
um uh before against or abstain or do we
agree by ascent
agreed everybody agreed no no perfect
thank you very much indeed that's
unanimously supported agenda item 18
appointments of Representatives to local
government and outside bodies is
deferred
agenda item 19 appointment of members to
serve on working groups is deferred
agenda item 20 this is the annual report
of the overview and scrutiny committee
which is found on pages 37 to 42. I now
call on councilor Paula spensely to
present the report Council spenceley
in your pack I'm going to just highlight
some little bits from it rather than go
through the whole thing and bore
everybody to death so
um councilor Helm was obviously our
chairman last year and I served as as
the vice chair under him so
um I'm going to go through the updates
after I said what the item is the parks
team culture and health and safety
concerns was something that had been
brought forward to the committee from
when councilor bill was was chair the
update on that is that the working group
received an update report in August 2022
and agreed that the issues having been
highlighted had largely been resolved
looking at what we've just been talking
about there The Five-Year land Supply we
had an item before us looking at a
potential lack of resilience and
robustness of process
as I think um all of all of the previous
members will remember very well as a
result of of the um committee looking at
that it was agreed to recommend that the
council paused the review methodology of
the ldp which was being under review at
the time or and that all members were
invited to an extraordinary meeting of
the council to consider options with
regard to the methodology used and to
consider a partial review of the ldp
rather than a full change to the
council's current strategy as a result
of that the council accepted the
committee's recommendation and set up a
working group to deal with this
the next thing was a notice of motion
relating to a successful planning appeal
an award of costs against the council at
a Burnham on Crouch site
um added to that scrutiny item there was
a reference from the July 2022 meeting
of the council this Rose from another
appeal decision and an award of costs in
relation to a site at Burnham on Crouch
the council having emphasized the need
for more objective and evidence-based
decision-making in the future and so we
looked at planning decision making
um we agreed um the following as a
committee to to recommend to council and
that was a review and refresh of the
planning appeals protocol which has
still got to happen uh views and
conclusions on member training uh
limited to concentrating on bespoke and
specialized training and review and
Improvement of Officer reports the
council at its meeting in February 2023
accepted that the committee's
recommendation on that
um and planning enforcement is another
item that's been referred to us and
processes and very quickly to say and
this is quite important at the March
meeting of the committee of further
report on progress was received and it
was agreed that this should be added to
the scrutiny work plan with a focus on
policy review Staffing resource and
other ongoing performance review issues
I think it's really important to
emphasize now that I I really hope that
the when the committee is reconvenes
with new members that that really is
looked at and taken forward as a
scrutiny item because we were making
real progress I think on that
um staff exit questionnaires
um that's a review that was a reference
from PG a performance governor and audit
committee on September 22 2022 even and
the committee adopted that to add to its
scrutiny work plan item and um that's
going to continue forward as well
we had we looked at the cyber security
update is all I'm going to say about
that one here
um no then there was a further one which
um we looked at with regard to a
potential Council of conduct tissue
which again was resolved that that
should be taken no further
um in terms of the scrutiny
um as a scrutiny item and very lastly
here safeguarding of children and
vulnerable adults a corporate risk
update on that that was referred to us
because of the risk identified in the
audit report and that's an ongoing work
and we're hoping uh we're not hoping
it's got to happen in the light of
information received as the work in
progress the committee agreed to review
the matter before the end of September
2023 and I just want to quickly say and
thank other members of the working group
for that of that committee which we did
meet quite regularly this year and we
did have quite a heavy workload and I
want to thank um councilor Vanessa Bell
for a membership of that as well as
counselor who of course isn't with us
now in councilor Helm and just to say
that I really hope that scrutiny has
taken seriously going forward because
it's much more important than I think
sometimes you know it's been it's been
judged to be
so a recommendation that I have here
please is that I would like to move that
the annual report of the overview and
scrutiny committee for
2022-23 is accepted by members thank you
chair thank you Sarah
thank you councilor Bell secondary
um again members we agree to the
recommendations I sent thank you very
much and thank you councilor Spencer for
all of the hard work the diligence and
thank you all members of the working
groups who have here and passed who have
put so much in uh some as passion and
commitment to help improve our processes
thank you very much that's moved so we
move on to agenda item 21 which is found
on pages 43-46.
um this is a review of members special
responsibility allow allowances again
page 43-46 this is going to be presented
by Mrs cardi via Terence remotely
thank you chair
um the purpose of this report is to
present the recommendations of the
independent remuneration panel on
special responsibility allowances known
as sras
local authorities are required by the
local authorities members allowance
regulations of 2003 to establish and
maintain an independent remuneration
panel to make recommendations on the
levels of basic and special
responsibility allowances that are paid
to councilors
the panel must meet every four years but
can be convened more regularly to review
any allowances requested
at the council meeting held on the 15th
of December 2022 members asked that the
current sras have been reviewed by the
panel to ensure that they are fairly
implied and consistent with other
authorities
benchmarking data was collated to be
used by the panel along with details of
the frequency of meetings and
responsibilities that attract the so the
SRA payments in order
the panel made on the 17th February 2023
and reviewed this data
their report is attached by appendix one
the panel was of the opinion that
overall subject to two recommendations
the SRI is currently paying to elected
members that are being fairly applied
and well consistent with other local
authorities
the two recommendations were that the
role of the district planning committee
chairman be awarded an SRA at 37.5 as
the role is currently not receiving an
SRA
and that the SRA currently paid to the
role of the overview and scrutinary
committee chairman be amended to 37.5 to
reflect the infrequency of meetings and
the workload
attempts always ask to consider these
recommendations
thank you Mrs cardi that's Siri kind
counselor's stamp I believe you wish to
speak I do chairman thank you very much
um thank you Mrs cardi for that
presentation I'm afraid I don't agree
that the uh over in scrutiny should be
reduced in fact I think it should be
kept at what it is
um I think Council Spence they very
adequately said exactly all the hard
work that was done that was called in by
a few members and and as the new members
won't be aware but the old members will
that I was chair of PG PG a and we
really wanted to work more closely with
our over and go to the committee because
that's how this Council should really
work and they should be working together
from committee's chairman and I actually
do not agree with that so um I'd like to
make a an alternative proposal that it
is kept the same and I also chairman
would like to say that the district
planning committee comes back under you
is the chairman of the council and you
chair it so the the remunerations would
stay exactly the same but you would have
the added responsibility which I think
always happened before
um I think councilor ex Council would
actually maybe support former sorry
former councilor Boyce um uh would agree
with that
um so I would like to say their
amendments are alternatives chairman
whatever Mr quilch allows me to do
because he's looking at me now thank you
thank you councilor stamp I will refer
to uh Mr Welch
so that is the proposal okay but it
sounds to me as if it was two changes
yeah so it's that it remains as it is
yeah so thank you so go cancel the stem
but councilor Samba said so really your
proposals are saying that it stays as
what it is
if the easiest way to say because the
these no I'm not I'm saying the
allowance does but the proportionality
on who you award it to doesn't so my my
my emotion or my Amendment would be that
we refuse your recommendations if it
goes to vote and that the district
planning committee goes back under
your your remit and uh over in scrutiny
stays exactly the same
so that's the proposal
individuals it is yeah so basically he's
leaving it as it is because currently I
I'm the Champion oh sorry I do apologize
yeah a bit slow sometimes chairman you
should be used to that
So yeah thank you very so with the The
Proposal you put in there is basically
keep the same Arrangements that we have
currently thank you I've got everybody's
name hand up Council Cedar was next
please
uh thank you chairman yeah we want to
ensure that overview news security is a
robust committee and is valued for the
work that it does at this Council so
therefore I really don't understand why
the vice chairman of that committee
doesn't get an allowance uh so I think
that we need to again reflect uh you
know the the importance of that
committee and therefore you know that
the chairman the vice chairman of that
committee should get 25 of the normal
allowance of the chairman of that
committee because I know with councilor
spencerley and also with councilor Bell
and he's like in the past they have done
a lot of work when they've been the vice
chairman and there is an allowance for
that
committee
very much uh councilor spensely thank
you
thank you chair it was an honor and a
privilege to do it but you're quite
right I didn't get anything for it but
anyway
because I just asked it for a second
there for counselors thank you my
apologies councilor thank you
I'll wait to you can I carry on sorry
about that account suspensely thank you
thank you chair so what I wanted to say
was that my concern with this
[Music]
um
and actually that I I didn't because I
haven't been here I don't want to say
that I haven't been here a long time
because I always get told off for that
but because I didn't know that the chair
could take over District planning I was
worried about the district planning
element but
um
my concern with this was that overview
and scrutiny could be in a sense thought
of as less important than it is and I
have had a sense in all honesty that we
we need to be meeting more often the
workload needs to be a bit more intense
and so actually it would seem rather
strange to be reducing the allowance
when we should be perhaps
stepping that committee up and that's my
feeling on that so I'm minded to agree
with cancer stamps proposal thank you
thank you very much indeed cow
suspensary councilor Thompson please
um thank you chairman um I've got issues
in account website issues in a couple of
areas one I know is that the vice
chairman of the council's special
responsibility allowance appears to only
be remaining at 10 which given that we
have two main centers of population two
towns and the vice chairman is often
very busy I'm not sure why the vice
chairman of the council would have a
lower responsibility allowance than Vice
chairman of committees
I I would like to suggest that that
could be 25
um the the other thing um given that we
don't even know who it is yet
um the other thing I'm I'm a bit
concerned about District planning and
and we might need Mr Quilter's help
through you please my understanding is
it's a committee it's a council it is
not the council sitting as which it used
to be and therefore should it not be
free to elect its own chairman rather
than have one dictated to it and from
the Chairman's point of view the
chairman of the council's point of view
they might find their foot in a very
awkward position on occasions on account
of you know because
because District planning is regulatory
um there might be some confusion between
the chairman as the face of the district
and the representative from the district
and sharing a regulatory committee
um and I'd be very grateful for some
advice please thank you thank you
yep
let me just check
okay we're just checking um just a
couple of points before we come back on
that Council Thompson
because it always was when I first
arrived
I just I want to check in terms of
reference
in terms
of just so new members now we're just
checking to terms of reference to be
able to give out an informed answer
five minutes
yeah okay members what we've decided to
do we're going to have a five minute
adjournment and then we'll come back
with information so I joined a meeting
at
806 for five minutes
all right
foreign
okay members and members of the public
thank you we're just resuming the
business at 8 17 p.m
um thanks to everybody for your patience
and understanding we just wanted to make
sure that the information that we we
pass over is constitutionally correct as
regard to uh councilor stamps uh
proposal which has been seconded there's
nothing in the Constitution that the the
chair of District the chair of the
council becomes the chair of District
planning
um it's a an informal convention that's
just something that's been happening all
the time so it's not something that's
written in the Constitution that that
has to maintain uh it may or may not
um so that would actually impact
slightly on the wording of your motion
and that we keep everything the same
um
that's where we are but for you the
emotion that counts as Stampers as as
tabled we need to vote on that
um is everybody clear on what the
emotion actually is
okay Tara Alberta sorry did you catch
what it was
well my understanding was that we would
remain with the currents with the
current structure of a special
responsibility allowances thank you so
we need to go to that
um
uh councilor Thompson
thank you chairman I I thought councilor
siddle and I made amendments and perhaps
well I was too slow sorry I probably
would have um
uh sorry for you chairman I was was mine
I'm not sure if it was even requested
but anyway we're in your hands Jim
yeah I think that yeah um members all
members need to make it clear that
you're making an amendment and so we can
call for a second so it's really clear
and we don't get things missed so thank
you uh councilor fluka thank you yeah
thank you chairman I thought Jim and I
just take this brief opportunity just to
remind members and and the new members
how this report came and the reason why
this report is here chairman is is when
we were talking about the members basic
allowance and there was a long and
protracted debate in here whether or not
to increase it chairman and and I can
remember saying look this Council
financially is in a very difficult
position I don't think it looks good if
we increase the members allowance and uh
and since then chairman I've actually
said that any increase that I received
to the basic allowance I'll donate to
Charities and and Community groups in in
southminster but the reason why chairman
this the reason why I was concerned
about this and and I'm disappointed that
the remuneration panel didn't pick up on
because I had been promised that they
would contact me because I felt so
concerned about certain areas and one of
the areas that I was concerned about
chairman is is the vice Chairman's
allowance of the main committees timing
the vice chairman of one of the main
committees gets 1200 an additional 1200
pounds a year so generally speaking
there's six six meetings so that's 200
pounds of meeting and I think if you
look at each meeting with the
um if you allow a couple of hours from
the gender meeting which I doubt it is
and and I'm two or three hours for the
main meeting which they tend not to be
um it sort of equates to about 40 pound
an hour it's quite a lot bearing in mind
the people that voted for these
increases won't even pay the nurses are
proper wage
um so chairman it that that was where
this was all about to make sure it was
good value and and uh and of course one
of the chairman only managed to make it
to three meetings chairman so he was
actually learning four 100 pound meeting
which I
which uh I I find that's very difficult
to explain to the public Bernie Manuel
steer at times we live in German and the
cost of living crisis I mean I think 400
pounds a meeting is a lot of money and
I'm disappointed chairman that they um
they didn't pick up on that and I'm
equally disappointed that they didn't
speak to me
um tonight we seem to be spending even
more money
you know we're already in deficits
um and this is just adding to it so I
think chairman you know moving forward
through this Administration we should be
very very careful that whenever we spend
money we are always thinking about
balancing our books
and to that end chairman I I would
propose and uh that we don't increase
the of we we revert the members basic
allowance to back where it was
um I mean I know this causes a
constitutional crisis Mr quilts because
Council has made a decision but chairman
if we were to revert back I've not done
the figures but I think that would
certainly cover all these additional
expenses tonight and I think it would
you know I think it would show to the
public that we're actually trying to
close these budget deficit and then
we're not spending money on ourselves so
I'm sorry to put you in that condo and
I'll leave Mr quelch to answer that
question
they say
is a different subject
to this pool which is to deal with
special slaves and I think agent would
need to put a notice of motion in
not just
in a sense is coming in on the back yeah
it's not basically
brilliant okay thank you he can do it he
can put a notice of motion in yeah
I'll think of thank you councilor Fluker
it's um
it's always very informative when when
you speak
um
this report is uh for for basic sras and
I think we're talking about basic
allowances which is a different matter
so I think for this evening we do have a
recommendation on the table which has
been seconded but before I move that I'm
just going to move to uh councilor
Durham who had his hand up earlier thank
you chairman I I just really wanted to
raise the question that councilor stamp
did about the importance of the role of
the chairman of the OV and scrutiny
committee because
I think scrutiny is being undervalued
and it is absolutely crucial I can only
just
um
highlight that the County Council there
are four scrutiny committees and the
actual special responsibility allowance
for chairman of the scrutiny committee
is the highest all but the leader and
Deputy leader it's considerably higher
than the deputy cabinet members who are
equivalent of of the committee chairs so
you know it it would be
if it was equivalent it would be
actually about a hundred and fifty
percent
um for a scrutiny chairman
thank you very much and do you councilor
down cancel the bill please
thank you Mr chairman I'm disappointed
that councilor Fluker doesn't um want to
include ordinary working people on this
Council I know I'm not the only
counselor that actually had to give up
paid work in order to give this role my
full attention and the attention that it
deserves
very well and good if you can afford it
but if you can't
because you can't afford to put food on
the table thank you Mr chairman thank
you very much indeed councilor bill
um well we do have the motion on the
table which has been seconded and the
basically I'm I'll just present that I
um was the chair of District planning
and received no additional payments nor
did I seek it
um I have a personal view if if that's
the driver then you need to look at
yourself there but that's my personal
view
um so we do have that recommendation
motion by councilor stamp that the um
roles and remunerations at this moment
in time remain the same that has been
seconded I'd like to put that to the
vote members so if I could have a shower
hands four councilor stamps motion
so one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen sixteen Seventeen
eighteen nineteen twenty four those
against
one against any abstentions please
can pop your hands a little bit higher
because I've got dodgy eyes one two
three four five six
seven against thank you so that motion
is counted I'm sorry one abstain sorry
counselor so that motion passes so thank
you very much indeed Council stamp
foreign
as we move on to item number 21 rather
quicker than I was expecting and this is
a business by any reason of special
circumstances considered by the chairman
to be urgent uh councilor Durham wish to
speak yeah chairman just very very
quickly and it's it's not relating to
this uh having whoops look looked at the
looked up at the board of past chairman
um and to see that in 1981 to 83 it was
Mrs Patricia Hermann
um whose picture is up there the fifth
from the left at the top and I happened
to see her and only Mr Holmes probably
will remember Mrs Hermann a very uh
redoubtable character she looks exactly
the same as she does there albeit gray
is 96 years old and is still bright as a
button and I just thought for the
interest of members it would be nice to
know that she's still going strong and
my predecessor unfortunately council Mrs
Young although still alive is in a home
with dementia but as I said councilor
Mrs Hermann who would be one of our
oldest serving living members is as
sprightly as she ever was thank you
thank you very much indeed for inform us
of that um the Urgent business there is
none so members I now come to the
closure of the meeting members thank you
for your contributions this evening I
now close this meeting at 8 27 pm
at the meeting is now closed members are
advised uh not to advise